mon nom et adja tâche à trous la vache
patel allez mange il va bien falloir que
tu prennes des forces si tu veux que je
t'amène à paris un jour quand j'étais
jeune je ne savais rien du tout du reste
du monde
et un jour j'ai reçu la mauvaise dubai
moment maman je t'amène à paris
[Musique]
l'amour à paris est dix fois plus fort
que n'importe où sur terre
chérie je trouve plus mes clefs de
voiture désolé j'ai vraiment besoin de
tester un salon avant d'acheter entre
marié moi le courant est passé
immédiatement
je lui ai tout petits de l'ain
alors à demain soir à la tour eiffel ok
oh ici à paris on se fait la bise sur
les jeux o
comme je n'avais pas d'argent
j'ai décidé de passer la nuit sur place
c'est celle là où elle pourra donc
l'autre c'est complet il faut que je
retourne à paris
le karma ça marche à chaque fois
vous êtes un réfugié oui j'ai à ton
particulier je peux lire l'avenir dans
la circulation
[Applaudissements]
oh
le hasard fait tout on joue avec les
cartes qu'ils nous distribuent
et voici les cartes que le hasard m'a
distribués
[Musique]
hadja c'est toi seul kilomètre de
thaksin
e
c'est tous des clandestins ou patois je
suis en touristes qui voyagent dans une
halle oui